all right y'all we're about to uh get
into the Hit Boy
big hit interview and there is a
discrepancy with the interview
Pit Boys camera angle did not record
properly we had an issue with the SD
card so if you're watching the interview
you won't see hit points you'll hear him
talking
if you think that's weird you can just
go listen to it on Spotify and on Apple
all right uh but yeah you know 340
interviews we had a [__] up all right
shots of Hit Boy and big hit let's get
into it
yo bootleg Kev show bootleg cab podcast
special guests are here they just
dropped a joint album it's only right
big hit hit boy sir what's the deal bro
um it's crazy because you and I have
done a bunch of interviews and we always
talk about when your Dad's getting home
all right and you're home man welcome
home brother right for sure good looking
good luck I gotta say I've never seen
somebody any rapper ever come home maybe
boozy and just be just non-stop dropping
[__] like you came home on a mission bro
yeah yep overdue Mission man we uh
non-stop Mission uh how long were you
going eight or nine years yeah yeah it's
crazy you could probably tell me when
grinding my whole life ended up coming
out you're obviously you're in the music
video it's a moment uh the hs87 album
comes out
were you able to kind of like see like
the G-Unit remix of that song and all
that stuff when you were out or did that
all happen like what what what at what
point in time did we was in New York
when uh we actually thought the song was
our song we was riding in New York and
we heard it we heard him we like what
the [__] like my [__]
you need to holla at you yeah no that
was a crazy moment because like like you
said I think a lot of people especially
on the East Coast had kind of like
for people who don't know the last time
he was on the show he had a dinosaur
mask on right right you're gonna have to
cut to that don't forget his iPad
the iPad is a must sure
um no but I I think a lot of a lot of
people who weren't hip to what y'all
were doing assumed that was like a
G-Unit record
that was wild that was wild like I
remember we uh we was in New York like
you said we landed we heard that joint
and we actually pulled up on uh 50 and
chopped it with him that day and the
[__] was like showing love like he was
breaking down [__] versus knew who
everybody was on the song I had the
whole Squad out there in New York you
know what I mean so he I mean but then
it kind of just like
fast forward just kind of was like
[__] they low-key just snatched the
swag up they did for sure that's one of
my favorites I mean I was like the last
uh you know time [__] took G-Unit
serious was like oh North swag so that's
actually not too far from the truth in
terms of a group I don't know if anybody
else I don't literally is the truth that
was the last moment they had you know I
mean because they had even what was that
random dude that a kid kid was on it
right what's that who's on it kid kid
was on that remix I think so one of the
random dude who ended up in junior yeah
I don't know he said that he said that
man you dropped you brought G Unit back
my [__] gave me a hug yeah you feeling
yeah you know what I'm saying
um what was did you guys plan this on
phone calls this whole like hey are you
telling him like yo son I got
I got these wraps ready or you do did
you come out with this a notebook full
of [__] man it's a noble trash bags yeah
a lot man you know a lot well you know
we was in contact the whole time though
so I was on the thing thinking we was
keeping in contact like he put me on his
last CD when the Surfers round one yeah
he started it off with a rat from prison
so I remember that I was just ill for
him to he owned nine out of 10 songs on
this one you know what I mean it's only
right
um for you uh hit I know like how
important it is to have your dad home
man like it's dope too to kind of
you're having like your Renaissance I
feel like you're like in your like
95 96 97 Jordan years right now
for sure you're upset like you could
like dad comes home you got four albums
out with nas a Grammy per album of the
year like no I mean even just like it's
just crazy like when you just put stuff
in retrospect like working with knives
and working with a mature rapper like
you know in a different age bracket than
I am or whatever the case is it just
prepared me for like recording big hit
like it was just like a layup soon as he
came in we just like he had a he had
like 100 songs and he only been on for
two I mean a month and a half a month
you guys recorded 100. he's recorded
like a hundred songs yeah Jesus not even
exactly yeah that's crazy man
um are you pre are you free from uh like
paperwork are you finally like yeah I'm
mine on [__] they they held me like six
years over my time man you know
political prisoner type [__] right but
uh yeah I got some Millions coming from
them lawsuit oh nice so you're gonna
you're shooting uh is it the correctness
of the state and you know the judge all
the should the prosecutors
yeah they gave me the legal sentence
they knew it was illegal before they
gave it to me what was it for if you
don't mind me asking okay yeah a car
accident yeah yeah hey I may or may not
have hit a car in a parking lot and it
kept it moving
I've been in the position where I've
done it at least seven or eight times
when I was like 20 22 no insurance might
tap somebody you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah no this some [__] [__] just
trying to rob me you feel me I'm coming
from Humboldt County with like a hundred
pounds of the tree and the news is on we
hitting red lights running [__]
shooting all kind of [__] and we crashed
and jumped out and ran but the other
people got hurt so they were saying that
you know basically the whole argument
was saying that I should have stopped
and assisted the people in the car who
were trying to rob you but there was no
no the other people
some parties try to pull over but we
clipped them in the back and they
flipped over got hurt
so so when it so so essentially because
because people don't know Humboldt
County is like a wild place like oh yeah
it's like it's like Narcos in the forest
out there yeah that too but it's a
lawless Lane man I guess it's short it's
off the map you got a lot of spots
that's even off the grid you don't you
can't even Google them you know they
just Word of Mouth you can't live in
that Community unless you're growing
trees and all kind of [__] like you're
not welcome no for sure uh we had burner
on the show and he told us the story
like how he had to go up a mountain to
pick up like I think it was like a box
like 100 pounds or something yeah and he
was he was afraid uh yeah so essentially
something similar kind of had happened
yeah he was just explaining how crazy it
is up there it's like they got their own
language just telling me how uh you was
like you had didn't know nobody you was
like talking to the homeless people yeah
yeah when I got out I was handed by
Humboldt County you know he's always
buying that Mexican with compressed
Brown [__] and then that kush came about
like [__] it I gotta go up here I just
went up there with a pocket full of
money hanging out with the bombs and you
know the the homeless people and [__]
they point you in the right direction or
what no that was the man this [__] the
homeless people was the demand they were
saying I ended up you know that's how I
linked up with them we was just going
out hanging out just you know they was
hungry and [__] buying a fool like
everything he wanted I was buying oh
[__] gotta get some fun we're gonna get
some drink they used to be talking like
man go and get what you want and I'm
buying a food I just need some weed you
know I got some weight come on the back
of the stores like a river back there
with tents and they living oh yeah and
back at the bottom River and just a
trail Full Of Weeds plants you know what
I'm saying like what the [__] now the
homeless dudes they they're like growing
they're like growing they're growing
along the river Gorilla growing you know
what I'm saying but uh is it kind of
crazy for you to get out because I mean
obviously when you went in it was it was
legal it was medically legal no hell no
it was medically I don't think it was it
might not it might have come on just
last eight nine years yeah yeah yeah it
was converting it but how crazy is it
now because like now you're out and this
[__] is like really just like yeah this
is the game is messed up you can't
really make no money off of it you know
what I'm saying this is [__] up
especially yeah because I you know
they're so with these dispensaries and
the taxes and like you know it's just
wild though cause like we just did this
event called uh Olympics with Gucci Mane
and burner and that [__] was like it's
like the wheat Olympics just in the
middle of downtown oh yeah like 10 years
yeah yeah yeah like 10 years ago if you
would have told me I'd be like hanging
out in downtown L.A and just there's
just an open drug market and there's
police at the door and like like what
the [__] is going on yeah and there's
still people somehow like incarcerated
in California for yeah for a week yeah
they do it up there too Reggae on the
River you don't say everybody come there
with their special trees they don't
cloned and special you know hybrids and
[__] showing off they they little [__]
if you come come up there and they go to
the dispensaries and they regulate the
clones and right you know that's the
thing get that main strain where they
don't nobody have it and try to keep
that strain and boom right yeah yo
getting out after uh eight or nine years
sitting down
obviously you have TV you have some sort
of awareness what's going on but what
was like the one thing once you're out
and free that you saw that you were like
oh this [__] is different like was it
like a Tesla was it like uh [__] because
Tesla's weren't popping when you went in
there were these electric cars you know
what I'm saying yeah I'm not really
impressed but I don't know why but
um [__] uh
I can't really think not enough were you
surprised by how many homeless people
were set up in tents in LA
no I mean when I came home the first
time it was like that I was tripping in
yeah it was like damn you know all these
dudes is homeless and down there
grinding and all them dudes ain't broke
y'all says down there getting it but uh
but yeah that's I I don't know I can't
really say what was hella hella hella
different it was just he had a phone
that's what I'm saying you had a phone
yeah it was upgrade you were on
Instagram the whole time yeah I'm
staying booming no I'm saying yo are you
able to have a phone or is that
considered no hell no because
everybody's got a phone in jail right
yeah I'm like if you got the bread you
can get it money talk [__] what
because the CEO don't care right you
know I mean they'll just keep it I mean
they gotta feed they kids too you feel
me so yeah 100
um okay so the new album is out you're
on 99 of the album all right
um is this what is because because the
last time we talked to you I think you
did a distro deal with that with the
company introduction Street yeah yeah
are you still with them it I put that
out I put it out through varric and it's
just like being with varic it just
allowed me to drop music how and when
I'm free you know what I mean if I was
on a major with my rap stuff then it
would be like you know it would take
three months to get one song out so now
it's like I got two albums out in three
months and you know I mean I'm just
building my fan base up and it's just
like it's like he came on we got 10 000
followers in a month like literally
getting more engagement than some
rappers I know you know I mean for sure
some of his posts go off more than mine
it's like you know I mean it's just like
it's I see real people be becoming like
big hit fans like man this this [__] is
like my favorite rapper right now it's
just wild to see no it is crazy because
it's almost like damn like
right away he touches down and like I
feel the same way I'm like yo this
dude's putting out harder [__] than like
99 of these and I feel like you're
feeling a void in fact there's like a
void for like the [__] you're doing like
I like authentic West Coast yeah for
sure like somebody you like really
believe is on that you know I mean a
hundred percent nah for sure and even
just like the Beats like the flow like
it's not you know we I mean you know we
are in LA
we've been listening to the same dudes
rapping the same way foreign like the
last five or six years everybody's some
sort of Draco Shoreline clone you know
what I'm just not doing some like future
Thug Type [__] right man 100 man I don't
know what you're saying we're keeping it
up man this is authentically you know I
mean exactly what you looking at is what
you got you know I mean this is like
we've been plotting this out for even
before the you know grinding my whole
life [__] we was talking about doing
music and we had the music but it's just
like now it's like I'm my best he his
best he you know willing to work to stay
out of the [__] and that's like
that's that's one of the top things you
know I mean it's the bigger than just
you know my son popping I'm about to
just get on some songs and try to make
some money get famous whatever it's like
this [__] is really in our soul to do
this [__] like we've been talking about
it been locked in on it yeah would you
say for you like uh you're the most
motivated because I think before he
obviously gets to deal with the
Interscope right hs87 is [__]
I mean such a talented roster a guy shot
Audio Push can't money uh everybody uh
okay I was just talking about Kate
Roosevelt a couple weeks ago like Jesus
dude let's do me now man K Roosevelt was
like literally bro like the first Khalid
like they definitely got an identical
voice like bro but it's just like timing
is everything bro that [__] is you can't
call it and you can't just predict like
when it's gonna crack off for you on
that level you just gotta I was gonna
say obviously there's a gift and a curse
for everything to happen with you do you
feel like everything mentality wise work
ethic wise like you're fully like ten
toes in on the rap [__] now big hit oh
yeah mentally yup yup I mean as far as
like my heart right now really wasn't
into it like that you know I'm saying it
was just like I felt like I was it like
I missed my chance you know what I'm
saying from way back then I was waiting
so long so eager and [__] and uh but my
you know I was like trying to I was one
foot in one foot out trying to get my
bread you know was the status is
matching up like right now but my chili
ain't there man like you know I want it
right now you know what I'm saying so
but yeah but yeah I was like [__] it if
it worked it worked it's cool I'm the
same old you know I'm starting to feel
it a little more now I'm getting more
enthused because you know I'm [__]
with him on this Duo [__] that's more
energy he giving me energy I'm giving
him energy you know I'm saying it's
starting to work it's it's working I
mean you know I'm saying like we just
scratching the surface that's the funny
part we ain't even we ain't even Full
Speed Ahead yet right we're in first
gear right I've seen like so many people
reposting
the videos you guys have been dropping
who's for you who's been like the
craziest person you've seen like
obviously you got the shirt with uh with
yams but uh since you've been out repost
the music or maybe comment on something
or reach out uh probably Snoop yeah
Snoop called us the other night I sent
Sloop a song cause uh I had sentima uh
it's a clip online I had Cynthia my song
that's on Surfer drum volume two called
show me and I just was like I told him I
was inspired by Rhythm and gangster when
I made the joint great album he super
slept on Snapchat it's legendary he sent
me a uh that clip like saying like this
[__] hard then he was like man [__] man
your pop should get one so it's like we
I sent him a joint with an open verse he
called me like yo this [__] hard I'm
gonna see if I can come up with
something hit me big head chopped it
that was a moment
you and Nas aren't far apart in like age
right yeah now it's cool as [__] too on
me yeah you got to kick it as you kicked
it with nas yeah yeah like right before
Nas went back on tour Donna's just got
back but he uh right he was a big head
got out he came through Vibe with us
heard some music he was rocking with it
heavy you know what I mean that's crazy
he left on tour a couple days later
that's crazy for you hit what was like
obviously your generation what'd you
grow up listening to what who influenced
you oh [__] NWA man uh KRS you know what
I'm saying uh Biz Marky [__] like rest
in peace um yeah uncle Jim's army man uh
just all the old schools it's crazy too
because like even just hip-hop has
changed so much in in nine years right
like there's so much like there's good
[__] about it because I feel like
there's not a lot of Gatekeepers now
like you could just upload [__] on your
own and go straight to the people like
like you were saying like when y'all
were hs87 in the hinder scope situation
it's an uphill battle to do anything
right anything but also there's a lot
more [__] but like it's kind of
crazy like
I know he's fine he ain't picking up on
him he's fine
yeah it's fine he's fine
um but I was gonna say for you like
being a real dude who comes out and you
kind of see like there's all these
artists who are kind of like
I feel like the snitching thing is like
widely accepted in hip-hop now and like
there's so much like not real [__] like
you know like that's why I said you're
filling a void because there's
definitely like a void for like real
authentic Street La [__] that sound that
doesn't sound like I guess what we're
used to like but for you like do you did
you feel that when you came out they're
like when you start kind of seeing some
of the [__] that's going on in Hip Hop
or you're like man this [__] is kind of
turned into some weirdo [__] or no I
don't even listen to people's [__] man I
kind of was isolated like in the show
type I always isolate myself and uh I
just you know tell my story man what I
feel you were uh you were was it 23 hour
23 hours a day lockdown or yeah yeah
some well some days 24 you know Monday
Wednesday and Friday you go out with a
that's got to be crazy just to be 23
hours a day yeah yeah I mean like people
don't even know like you know he really
been locked up virtually since he was 19
years old he only been out a couple
times never for longer than a year
because you just got out before right
yeah yeah been out like six weeks
okay he was talking about when we did
grind them all life oh yeah yeah yeah
damn yeah hell yeah I did 15 years in
the fast and uh yeah got caught up time
to stay out right absolutely yeah yeah
30 years of your life and that jointed
that's that's that's a different level
it's important too to like you know I
think a lot of people who are
incarcerated feel like when they do that
kind of time to think their life's over
and yeah guaranteed you know it's I
think it's dope though that you can show
an example that like you know if you're
sitting down doing time there's there's
a light do you know what I'm saying as
long as you're breathing you in the game
beautiful it's real yeah what's the uh
if if what what's your go-to spread like
what are you putting in the spread
[__] in jail yeah in jail [__] uh
clams uh chicken
uh uh macro
yeah my wife thinks I eat like I'm in
pickles because I'll do the ramen you
know I'll crush up the ramen I'll put it
in a bowl she swears this prison food
that's the fat boy [__] man
I mean if you hungry though that it'll
work you know it'll stick on your
stomach I'll be seeing the day be doing
like Hibachi and [__] in jail if you see
that there's like a viral video where
they like make a Hibachi Grill in the
cell yeah and there's like straight
Benihana right yeah yeah yeah
that's just crazy yeah yeah I didn't get
to uh do all that but all right listen
I'm on vacation we're cutting
commercials live from Mexico we're on
the beach damn it so check this out man
don't forget it's summertime you got to
go to
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg all
right that's gonna get you a free month
supply same active ingredient as Viagra
and Cialis of course uh the best part
about Bluetooth is to get your dick
super hard what are we talking about all
right if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction do the stress due to
I don't know whatever is going on
mentally it happens too you can get that
Ed fixed Bluetooth promo code
bootleg three months Supply
bluetooth.com
also want to shout out to the family at
Odd Socks baby that's right shout out to
Odd Socks they got all kind of crazy new
licenses they just dropped uh man
Transformers they got the Hasbro
licenses now the Power Ranger sucks of
course they just did the Coca-Cola
earlier this year of course the most
comfortable socks in the world go to
oddsoxofficial.com use that promo code
bootleg and save 20 off
oddsoxofficial.com
um I was gonna say hit for you uh it's
been it's been a crazy last for three or
four years
um
in terms of just like some of the
moments that you've had obviously it's
been a crazy last like 12 years for you
but
um what's up is uh is the is the King's
disease series over
I mean I you can't ever say that me and
Nas we steady work and we you know we
definitely got new music you know we all
know exactly which way it's gonna go you
know that's Nas and he do what he do but
you know when it's time I'm I'm just
gonna be available but I can't say it's
over you know I mean I was gonna say how
many artists have hit you to kind of try
to do the same thing that you because
it'd be a nice it'd be a nice premium to
have a home fully produced hitboy album
definitely a few you know I mean like I
did the Benny album I did a couple
different joints but I mean me and Nas
we got a different level just a
different level of a personal you know
relationship like it's just like we that
should just be working we getting there
sometimes I get in with the artists and
it just we don't get nothing with knives
we always gonna get at least a verse a
hook something done like when you pull
up so that's just the ill [__] so we we
all just making music I was gonna say I
always go back and forth between whether
I like magic or King's disease 3 the
most out of your guys's bodies of work
yeah that's that's out here that all the
time I'm a magic person exactly mostly
be magic yeah and it's crazy because
magic is the one record that we just
woke up one day and it was just like
what the [__] yeah exactly but what's
your favorite
um I mean kd3 man I like all of them bro
I can't lie like I got special moments
that I just like feel super connected to
on every album but I feel like it's
progressively I think each project
somehow like it just kept getting better
yeah that's I mean you know I feel like
we just start yelling more like I start
getting more into my just history or Nas
music I'm from the West Coast so it's
like I didn't I only grew up here in the
nas hits I was on the radio my family
super West Coast so they wasn't playing
knives like that you know I mean so I
know I had some friends who their family
might have played knives but just as far
as my circle it wasn't you know
something that was embedded in me the
way like certain West Coast Music would
be like Snoop Dogg music or something so
I had to really learn and really study
them albums and really be like okay this
is what people like from him let me take
this and just mix it with what I do yeah
um I was gonna say you guys are you in
Alchemist put out the incredible
freestyle that went viral uh yeah
rapping over each other's Beats which I
thought was genius
uh I also think we don't get enough
Alchemist wrapping these days we need a
new Step Brothers out by the way but
would you guys do a whole project like
that Bros we already got one we already
got one bro we got like all slipping in
the darkness level like joints like you
know it's gonna happen when it happened
but and it's just you guys are both
rapping yeah we stacking them up like
I'll send him beats his and me beats and
we'll just go in send them back boom you
do a verse you do a hook like we it's
just it's ill like we're giving each
other direction just through sending
joints over and just like you know what
I mean do you guys like I wonder how
that works because like obviously you
guys are both all-time great producers
is it do you guys collaborate on the
Beats together is it like yo this is a
photo of [__] I got this a photo shoot
you got let's pick which ones we like
and then or is it like hey yeah you have
a loop he's got a loop group together we
honestly is so new of a process that we
we haven't even got to cook together yet
it's just been sentencing [__] back and
forth but we got we got a nice slow
amount of joints already just off that
so yeah I kind of feel like you what you
did with that was like the what Kendrick
did with the control freak or the
control record that was my exact
sentiment you know 100 just wanted to
challenge the game and have some fun and
raise some questions that's never like I
never said [__] was whack no I didn't
other than one person yeah yeah you know
I mean but it's like I never said the
rest of them dudes was whack I just was
like can do do this I never seen him do
this you know I mean I like that's
that's all it was putting in con put it
in in context in an artistic way did you
and hit make ever have a combo after
your guys's uh online back and forth nah
I just assumed it was like it was like
nice promotion for everybody right nah
that was great man for sure that was
solid I think I think you hit it on the
head because like uh who did I have oh I
had Eric Ballinger here and we were
talking about like the difference
between you guys yeah like Rick Rubin
doesn't make beats did you like
obviously I mean I feel like I'm sure he
made some of them classes Rick Rubin
says he he doesn't know how to do
anything he's there for his taste
I don't believe that I think that's the
older Rick Rubin I know he was in there
cooking something which I don't know he
said that he he doesn't make any beats
he's there for his taste and I feel like
I mean that's like kind of the lane
hitmakers and it's like you bring him
again because he's got an ear he's got
the writers and then you you got it all
you could take the NPC out and you could
you know there's nothing you can't touch
you know what I'm saying we're gonna
leave it at that yeah
Jesus I just saw did in Paris just have
a new certification yeah just went
diamond yeah crazy and it's crazy
because you know that was like a few
years before the streaming there so that
was like people really buying that song
that's that's like the difference in the
game now like I just feel like
it was like a little more earned back in
the day like I just seen I spice how
long she's been out less than a year she
got a billion streets like I'm like I
spices the game is it a wild place I'll
be like I think she's out streaming like
almost everybody except like Bad Bunny
and Drake that's that's incredible you
know whatever she did in her life to get
that blessing for sure but you know just
music Wise It's like wow this is the
heroin you know you gotta accept it I
guess I remember at your old house in
your studio you had like um you had the
Grammy and then you had there was like a
Michael Jordan photo or something and
then there was like um the canvas of
like when Jay and Kanye
I think they were doing it in Paris
today that was that was right there it
was a parent it was a picture in Paris
yeah
um it's crazy to think like how much
that record like kind of changes your
trajectory of like just hit boy like I
remember during that time there was like
you were you were like one of the young
producers around good music My Guy
lifted from Phoenix and did Mercy
um and I remember he was just telling me
all these stories about like being in
hotel rooms like back to back to back
with like yourself everybody everybody
what's like one of the craziest like uh
stories you could tell about like just
those days like working with gay working
with the good guys it's a lot man
definitely like that uh trip I'm sure
lifted is talking about we all went to
London one time and everybody was there
Sean pushing Two Chains you know
obviously yay just being locked in I
remember it was so crowded in the uh one
of the hotel rooms and everybody came in
because they was working on it was
either click or Mercy wanted two and
like Sean was sitting on the floor with
a mic like this like recording a hook
for one of them joints and I just I'll
never forget that Craig a was right here
change was in everybody was in there
just a room full of people and they just
was getting it done by any means like
right there
um obviously you and Connie kind of have
what I wouldn't say it falling out but
definitely not the greatest times in
terms of your guys's relationship how is
it is it is there any relationship at
all these days
um I mean
I haven't uh talked to him since we I
did the easy join with game like but I
ain't got no issues with you my uh I
heard that because I just worked on I
want to say who project I worked on
somebody project I heard they played him
a song like this is just a few days ago
somebody texted me like yo bro play yeah
your song and it was like yo we need Hit
Boy to pull up so I don't know you know
he's I hey I heard he's cooking right
now yeah I heard that too I heard he is
in the studio I heard so I'm with him
man for sure yeah I ain't got no issues
with yeah nobody I know Freddie's
working with him right now there's a lot
of them I heard about that yeah a lot of
Kanye he's got shoulder pads you know
what I'm saying yeah and no and no shoes
no shoes you're wearing the socks it's
kind of crazy man if anybody he I don't
even question it no more because I
remember when the early gay [__] the the
clothing I was like No One's Gonna wear
this oh yeah look man we might all be in
shoulder pads in like six months you
know that's fun I don't know if I can
take it there but I feel uh would you
and Benny do sequel to the album that
you guys did together we uh he announced
that me and out is doing his album
together like I got you know we've done
probably like 15 16 new songs I don't
know how many he goes is that the Def
Jam debut yeah okay yeah I don't know
how many he gonna pick out the batch but
he got some joints for Alchemists some
joints with me I know we got a couple
other producers in the mix too but
predominantly it's supposed to be me and
Alchemist and that's supposed to come
August 11th or 12th something like that
it's crazy you know who I want to see
you work more with because I feel like
some of the best records that were on
his best album from King to a goddess
Conway and you had your you that was
during that kind of same era that you
were working with Benny I remember being
in some of those sessions
um what's up would you would you uh work
with Conway again of course yeah nice
for sure I'll be I mean I'll be down to
work with whoever want to lock in with
me everybody be in their own pocket they
own Zone but when I cross paths I'm
gonna definitely I can give whoever some
[__] you know that's how I feel yo Pops
I'm curious when you're incarcerated you
know your son's out here doing this
[__] thing where you at do you
remember where you were at when you find
out you won a Grammy for album of the
Year hip-hop out of the year because he
had already had you know Grant a grant
you know but I'm saying like I feel like
this one was different
which one the king's disease one oh the
nice one oh [__] no I didn't even know
um for real it was probably in the hall
at that time
yeah uh yeah I was I think I didn't have
a phone at the time I wasn't tapped in
right yeah I was in yeah I was in the
hole yeah it was a little spurt I was in
the hole
but yeah when I found me and I knew it
was gonna run it up though yeah
like when you're in the did you get
Wi-Fi service in there like does the
signal come in well it does yeah but you
don't get like are you able to stream
like songs and [__] well if you gotta if
she's active yeah the account is active
right yeah yeah so you're able to like
listening
oh fire and he was sending me like
samples and [__] from The Joint like yo
cut this up oh [__] it was just still
being creative the best we could that's
fire when is your official solo album
coming or is that not are we doing the
duo thing nice solo coming that's the
next thing you dropping yeah we
mastering right now oh so it's finished
oh yeah the first one it's like like I
said it's like 100 some songs we're
gonna drop albums on albums more Duo
[__] solo my solo whatever it is we just
going all right you already know man we
got to stop the interview shout out to
my bookie right now if you go to my
bookie and sign up man I was just
playing roulette like live with a real
person spinning the ball on webcam at
the casino mybookie.ag
you can of course bet on baseball
but really you got to get down with the
casino they got the slots they got all
the card games Blackjack cracks uh
roulette table games galore it's a
full-fledged casino mybookie.ag and when
you sign up with that promo code bootleg
sign up right now use that promo code
bootleg they're gonna get you hooked up
with a first deposit bonus mybookie.ag
let's get back to the interview now if
you guys don't know about King pong
kingpong is all natural baby yes all
right we're talking about the leader
when it comes to tobacco-free natural
organic Leaf wraps if you're a smoker a
toader a straight west coaster you know
what I'm saying whatever you're into
King Palms they got it for you what's
great about
um these these are like one of the best
uh products that they sell now this is a
terpene infused tobacco-free leaf
and what's dope is you stuff your flour
into it
and then you press on the thingy you
know what I'm saying
and then you got flavor I'm going to
show you what it looks like when it's
stuffed
with some great tree from Jardin of
course
ah look at that
right get that thing stuffed up
the tip has got that flavor in it uh
wherever you're at man make sure you
check out the uh
um you know they got the smoke shops
they got those on lock they got
7-Elevens on lock we only smoking out of
King Palms baby you already know what it
is and if you go to
kingpoms.com
kingpom.com kingpom.com
and you use the promo code bootleg Kev
you will save 50 off at checkout half
off at checkout fifty percent off if you
go to kingpom.com and use that promo
code the promo code is down below go run
it up try some of these flavors too man
the peach pineapple the Strawberry
Shortcake they just got so much going on
there's also all kinds of dope smoking
accessories you can get half off y'all
what are we talking about save 50 off
kingpom.com promo code below it's either
bootleg or bootleg have them these promo
codes got my head hurt try both of them
all right one of them get you 50 off God
damn it anyway let's get back to the
interview I was gonna say um do you feel
like hit like uh you're hitting like
your stride because I feel like you're
you've always been consistent as a
rapper but I feel like in terms of just
like people giving you your respect and
your flowers and like the consistency
for you dropping your [__] do you feel
like it's finally there it's coming for
sure like I uh again like being signed
to the situation or just being in a
situation I am I can drop music way more
often so you know not to say or put no
blame on nobody but it's like if I'm
waiting months to put out a song or
months to put out a project like it it
does slow up the progress so now it's
like you see me apply a different level
of pressure that you ain't seen before
so that's why I just feel different this
time
um no I feel like the pressure is at an
all-time high man I mean I feel like
you've been on a run I mean at the
offset record you guys took that to
radio and then I saw I saw you at a
complex called this are you like were
you like an ambassador for Patronus is
that your Patron that's not my Patron
really nice yeah setups setups it's a
crib that was a shout out to Patron we
uh I was just helping them promote the
new uh tequila El Alto yeah I mean it
just we went down to the Hacienda in
Mexico last July watch them make the
patron literally like every step from
going to the farm the fields with the
agave and all that like it was just yeah
I gotta ask you big hit
have you tapped in with only fans since
getting out are you aware of only fans
only only fans some of the porn [__]
yeah of course
because this was not a thing but you
wouldn't there was no only fans like a
girl who works at McDonald's could get
the [__] popping online there's teachers
who are teaching kids right now who are
also doing things on the internet for
extra money you know what I'm saying
it's a different world it's a hard time
out here yeah it's not like the days of
maximum magazine and all that [__] that
shit's a rap you know right yeah have
you have you got have you signed up I
didn't sign up personally but nah uh I
was on PornHub y'all just go through it
you know what I'm saying yeah no
pornhub's wild for sure what's the go-to
category and porno yeah threesomes
big black [__] black [__] with ass
threes you know I just saw like uh did
not age well do you remember Pinky
oh we gotta talk wait wait I forgot
about that that just reminded me I'm
like because I just saw this head yeah
pinky all right I woke up this morning
and they flagged me and took my post
down I seen that like as soon as I woke
up this morning okay yeah I I did not
mean to bring up the porn thing and get
into your porn thing because I didn't
know this I just saw this like a couple
days ago yeah so you used to score porn
movies yeah so I was uh we just went
back to uh Pasadena and shot this Monte
Carlo video with Dom Kennedy and I used
to play it looked like it was just a
house party that was a party at the park
we were just kicking it yeah so my my
cousin used to uh like be a coach up at
the park we was at so I started thinking
about my cousin I was like damn this
thing used to direct like big time
pornos like he had did some [__] and he
used to buy Beats for me he was give me
like a thousand dollars I'm like 18
making My First Beats my like this I had
only been making beats for two years at
that point and he started cashing me out
for Beats he was doing it on a real
level you know what I mean so I just
thought about that pinky scene oh wait
so you have a beat back one of your
Beats is playing during a pinky scene
yeah I just I have posted it on my gram
and they took it oh you found the scene
I found the scene yeah oh God and that
[__] was going up online like and then
you know IG hated on me I guess because
the little nipples out or whatever I was
gonna say uh do you remember the name of
the DVD because this is the DVD it was
like it was like art Angels oh yeah she
was like painted and they had like a six
four out there like yeah that was oh
that sounds like a big production real
West Coast uh porno production do you
remember when Snoop dropped his porno
yeah for sure
I was like I remember thinking like
there's no way snoops on here for he
wasn't obviously but it was just like
the most random porno of all time and
they they just definitely you know my
cousin who was older than me bought it
because Snoop was on the car it worked
they made money oh yeah for sure yeah
there's a few rappers have done that I
think yeah uh no it's funny though
because uh hip-hop DX they made a post
and made it seem like I was actually in
the porno so I had to repost it and let
[__] know like nah they took my [__]
and put it in a whole different context
but it is what it is my cousin used to
invite me to the set since yeah I used
to see the [__] cracking like damn it's
a wild life yo pinky were you there for
the pinky shirt I wasn't no Pinky's a
legend she's also like a [__] low-key
or she's like a tiny little like seeing
like more recent pictures of her she
definitely looked different than she did
in them days but yeah you know shout out
to pinky she's a legend nonetheless yeah
um Reckless and Ratchet on there on
PornHub
yeah you guys got to do a reckless and
Ratchet just branded
yeah why not we should perform that at
AVN or PornHub get at us yo hello
artists are doing the AVN Awards we
should definitely perform that that's
the perfect song G-Eazy just did it uh
tiger did it a bunch of you know I've
been saying that for sure
um I I just saw price just dropped his
new album last Friday
um what's going on with everybody else I
think octane's back to want to put music
out I just saw I've been seeing him drop
Clips yeah I mean you know everybody
doing their thing like price he he been
like on a different level of lock-in you
know I mean like he stay tapping in with
me we'd be chopping it sending ideas and
he didn't record it on some new beats of
mine within the last few months too so I
just say what's up with like cat money
and K Roosevelt and bmac I mean yeah
they they all doing anything I thought
bmac reached out when we dropped Surfer
Jones she showed love you know what I
mean can't money show love it's just
like everybody just doing what they do
locked in and I'm focused on whatever
what's Kate Roosevelt doing
he recording he uh you know if he play
instruments he locked in yeah that
shit's crazy he actually uh co-produced
the song with me on the music Soul Child
album that I dropped in March yeah he
produced co-produces song how different
well first of all shout out to um
because I feel like that kind of showed
a lot of people your range because
you've obviously done huge pop records
too but whether it's Rihanna Beyonce we
go on and on and on but like do a whole
album music Soul Child what's the what's
the creative uh approach to that like
you have to be in a different mindset
man that that music again like that that
so that was one where I was like that
DNA was already in me because my family
played his music so much right and I was
just such a fan of him I kind of just
knew where I could take it you know I
mean that he would be open to certain
musical choices that I was making
certain musicality levels that I'm
hitting he would understand it so it
kind of was like the same as the nausea
but just more melodic right uh pops What
is the what tell me what this your your
album that is just got turned in for
mixing and mastering is gonna sound like
man yeah
oh man it's just uh it's just basically
it's man it's a Vegas vague is very it's
dealing with everything it's going hard
just that's all I can say
it's going hard man West Coast have you
been pretty excited like for you to get
the validation to get out and get the
positive feedback you're getting that's
got to kind of make you feel like you're
on the right track like yeah yup I mean
I know I got a lot I got a long way to
go man I'm just like I said I'm just
scratching the surface I know I ain't
I'm not getting my just dude but I will
in in time because you're like an OG but
you're also a new artist so it's kind of
like yeah I mean I've never seen
something a lot of people doubt well you
know I'm gonna make them a Believer I
ain't tripping yeah I feel like I've
only seen people like excited but like
this shit's crazy like a lot of love 100
man
um what about you hit what any uh any
other
things down the pipeline that you could
talk about
man I'm working on all type of stuff man
uh I'm actually made a new song with
Jennifer Lopez that's hard I mean are
you in the studio with her I actually
it's funny because I I did my I've got
my first major label placement with her
in 07 and I just met her like a year ago
when we did the new song So wow it took
me some years that was your first
placement ever first label placement big
one yeah that's like always a big one
yeah was Ben Affleck hanging out yeah he
what no I think he might have came
through when I was there he might have
if you chop it up a band like hey dude I
love the town
not I was so many people in there and so
many creatives and just it was just a
creative Vibe yo I saw JLo's Vegas show
man she's fired bro I wouldn't hear
nobody you know I hear people talk [__]
about JLo as an artist I'm like bro I
watched her do like an hour and a half
straight she'll really dance she's a
real Entertainer singing she's an
Entertainer for real yeah for sure 100
man
um all right well look go get the uh the
new project is out right now sorry for
John volume two your album is on the way
yes sir sooner than later true stories
you shoot any videos yet for your [__]
uh
it seems like the videos you guys are
shooting just seems to be like you guys
taking cameras with you while you're
having a really good time just living
life really I mean we don't be having a
good time in general so that's what
that's what come off but we just yeah we
filming and just letting people see our
life I love it man um I'm super excited
to hear what your what your album
sounded like and obviously the new album
is dope everyone go run that [__] up Hit
Boy big hit we got the freestyle are
going to do too appreciate y'all man
that's all up top boom hey appreciate
y'all watching another interview brought
to you by our good Folks at hardean now
listen y'all when you're in Las Vegas
you get in that [__] Uber you land at
the airport hit that taxi tell them to
take you to hard Dean the number one
premium cannabis dispensary in the
[__] world y'all I'm telling you you
walk in they treat you like a king or a
queen or whatever you're into all right
they got the craziest selection to
premium cannabis you'll see period
anyway let alone in Las Vegas but just
anywhere all right not only can you go
get the best tree you won't get the best
experience the best customer service the
best bud tenders you walk in the hard
Dean and that [__] just smells amazing
they got their own [__] scent
literally you get into my car I got a
bottle of it my car smells like Harding
because it's just the best [__] place
um go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas
Harding underscore Las Vegas go to their
website Harding Las Vegas
all right when you go you're in Vegas
you'll pull up tell them I sent you
they're gonna take care of you the right
way all right look they got these things
in there man these Moon Rock uh
pre-rolls that I just had that just
absolutely melted my face off
shout out to hard Dean all right you
gotta go [__] with hard Dean man Harding
underscore Las Vegas uh thank y'all man
I love these guys they're like family to
us and uh hey we're gonna drop another
interview soon if you're watching this
you're at the end of the interview
though much love